I look Belinda at all and I was
thunderstruck by the difference in
delivery by the Secretary of State who
is advising her is this she and Bill or
is there a team of six is that like Game
of Thrones is there like 10 people
around her locked in a room saying no do
this who's driving the van I'm sure
there are more than 10 people in that
room and I'm also sure that it always
comes from the top if the the team
always reflects on the candidate and on
the principle so she is running this
campaign and yes she's launching very
differently from last time in a much
softer smaller way trying to get across
the message that this is as she said in
the video this is not about me this is
about you right motor does your time
whether i read bloomberg politics are
all the other rags would I notice
melinda is there's no real definition
here of momentum does she have momentum
I love this Olivia driving the van down
I 82 Iowa are you kidding she's driving
a van yeah she's calling it Scooby
Scooby the are you come on Melinda you
gotta be kidding me it's just stunts for
real well I think that in Iowa people
like to see you consuming that ethanol
product no I don't know I mean I van or
no van I think that she really wants to
underline that message that as she said
in the video I'm hitting the road and
I'm gonna earn your vote each and every
vote I'm going door-to-door you're gonna
see me many times and I'm gonna do
whatever it takes to earn that boat
Melinda of course Marco Rubio now
looking like he will be the third
Republican candidate to throw his hat in
the race we're looking for that
announcement at 6pm this afternoon I
from Miami would he be a formidable
Challenger to Secretary Clinton ish
won't think a lot of people think that
he has been underestimated that he's
very inspirational that he would
certainly address the problem that the
GOP has had in
evangel races and with the Hispanic vote
which was a particular problem in 2012
for Romney I think that he is a
fresh-faced and he's one of several
people who Republicans really are
willing to take a serious look at